so continuing the series that I've been
putting together each one including 10
vu shorts here's 10 more vu clips all of
these have to do with ethics and they
have to do with in particular moral
theories of one type or another you
notice that there's a lot of hedonism in
there but a little bit about natural law
a little bit about some of the other
theories as well so here they are 10
more clips
so do I think that it matters that our
sources for moral decisions are
conflicted and the question is making
some reference to I think the trolley
problem sort of a long standby a very
stark question that gets put in a lot of
intro to ethics classes when we were
first trying to pose you no moral
dilemmas I'm not very interested in the
trolley problem itself but I am
interested in this this question you
know what are the sources for our moral
decisions do we have the right sources
to begin with and are we giving them the
right weight and then what do we do when
they conflict so these questions are all
interrelated because figuring out what
to do when you have different sources
conflicting let's say you have
conscience telling you one thing and
perhaps a moral code which you know is
prevalent within your society telling
you another thing and somebody who you
whose opinion you trust and really
respect telling you a third thing maybe
they don't all jibe well then you're
posed with the problem of figuring out
which one to give the greatest weight
too and you know you can put this in
terms of logic vs emotion I don't find
that particularly helpful because when
people invoke logic or rationality not
as if there aren't different levels of
rationality or better and worse you know
logics if you're doing practical
reasoning about moral life whatever
you're calling reason has to be broad
enough to actually encompass the sort of
things that we're interested in so if
majak means you know just form a logic
that's not gonna be much use to you
a lot more to be said here but time's
running out so
so this is a good question from one of
my ethics students as well is hedonism a
good moral theory well it really depends
on what you mean by by good every moral
theory by virtue of being a moral theory
involves taking some sort of position on
what is right and wrong or what's good
and bad and how various goods you know
roll into each other or should be
arranged against each other or you know
what should be sacrificed to what or how
things should be ordered so hedonism
says that the only true good is pleasure
or the lack of pain everything else
friendship relationships duty reputation
virtue all those other sorts of things
are merely valued because they bring
about pleasure for the person involved
or they remove painful person involved
so that's how it defines the good and if
you stick strictly within a hedonistic
viewpoint you don't really have any way
of saying that it's not a good moral
theory right because by its own by its
own lights it would be a good moral
theory if pleasure is indeed the only
good then wouldn't it be better to be
straight about that and just go straight
after pleasure like Eris tipis advices
okay so that said if you want to ask the
broader question of whether it's a good
moral theory you have to figure out what
you mean by good so if you mean you know
something like respecting the rights of
others or promoting you know
self-development or leading a person
towards virtue and away from vice or
bringing a person to do their duty it's
probably not going to be a very good
moral theory and that may point view
towards the failures of hedonism it's a
kind of a restricted moral theory it
makes the world very small doesn't it
so this is a really interesting question
that a lot of my students were worried
about when I had them writing about
hedonism after I had been studying to
classical hedonist philosophers from the
ancient period eros tipis who basically
said physical pleasure is the good and
epictetus who said that mental pleasure
is actually better than physical
pleasure and that is the good if I do
want pleasure which I do we all do
actually right does that make me a
hedonist it's not enough just to desire
pleasure to be a hedonist because other
moral theories do take stock of the fact
that we human beings and actually all
sentient beings desire pleasure it's
whether you make that the be-all and
end-all of moral decision-making that
decides whether you're a hedonist or not
so if for instance you were to say I
really like shopping all right some of
my students wrote about that i really
like shopping i get a lot of enjoyment
out of it the app by itself doesn't make
you a hedonist it's deciding to
prioritize that let's say that's the
highest good for you shopping right at
the highest pleasure if you were to say
well I'm going to sacrifice everything
else to hop to shopping okay then you're
a hedonist right because you're pursuing
pleasure to the detriment or sacrifice
or you know exclusion of other goods you
know if you were to weigh all other
goods against and say well nothing as
good as shopping because shopping gives
me the most pleasure and you ignored
other things like say duty or virtue or
self development or relationships with
others yes then you would be a hedonist
but simply desiring pleasure by itself I
just makes you a human being that
doesn't make you a hedonist
and you be kind of hedonist without
being completely hedonistic yes as a
matter of fact this ties in with one of
the other answers that I just gave
recognizing that you in fact desire
pleasure and a reverse to pain is not
the same thing as espousing a hedonistic
lifestyle or moral theory or embracing
it you know wholesale can you be kind of
hedonist without being completely eating
this yes and no if by kind of a hedonist
you mean actually pursuing pleasure but
within certain limits limits that are
not just given by whether they're going
to lead you to other pleasures or
prevent you from having other pleasures
or things like that but limits that are
given to you from some other source that
doesn't just boil down last analysis to
pleasure like conscience or duty or
virtue or you know something along those
lines saying that those are not just a
matter of pleasure or maintaining a
relationship for example if you've got
those kind of limits and you're also
pursuing pleasure you would be doing
something heat in this dick but you
wouldn't be a hedonist yourself a great
example of this is Aristotle you know
Aristotle says pleasure is a good and
there's lots of pleasant Goods out there
and you wouldn't want to have a life
that doesn't include pleasure but
pleasure by itself is not the one single
value that you want to make everything
else turn around because that's kind of
a slavish animalistic kind of kind of
existence there's higher values and when
those higher values are realized by you
you actually do have pleasure in them
but you're not pursuing them just for
pleasure's sake so that would be not
being a hedonist right it would be a
hedonistic to a certain degree but not
hedonist
so this is a tough one how do you
distinguish a physical pleasure from a
mental one which is very important if
we're if we're looking at hedonistic
theories that is theories that say that
the good is pleasure and or you know
absence of pain how do we actually
distinguish these apart from each other
to classic hedonist eros tipis and epic
Epicurus differed on which we're better
you know Aris tipis at mental pleasures
they're not really that pleasurable
physical pleasures that's where it's at
Epicurus of the opposite said well you
know physical pleasures they're limited
and you got to keep repeating them or as
mental pleasures are more lasting more
fulfilling how do you distinguish them
though well you know there I think
there's going to be a lot of mixed
pleasures I think there's going to be
some that have a physical element but
are primarily mental pleasures you know
think about the act of reading for
example let's say you actually enjoy
reading as you know I would say most
students do right most people who
cranked books open do at least when
they're reading things that they like
what's being engaged is it primarily
your body or is it primarily your mind I
would say it's primarily your mind and
you could add physical things to it that
would improve the the pleasurable mess
of the situation but it's still
primarily a mental pleasure right so
sipping a coffee which is a physical
pleasure while you're reading your book
it's still primarily a mental pleasure
let's take a different example though
and that coffee but say wine or beer you
know if you're kind of a connoisseur
okay it's a physical pleasure right the
intoxication but the taste itself is
that purely physical or once you're your
palate has been educated is there a
mental component to it you know some
sort of cultivation that's taking place
I would say it's sort of mixed it's half
and half and so it really depends
doesn't
philosophy question not coming from one
of my students but somebody who
evidently has read some utilitarian in
theory and been highly impressed by it
should utilitarianism be considered the
morally conscious perspective in the
world as humans become more and more
interdependent know the word be there as
opposed to a that's the problem
utilitarians will often think that they
can subsume all other moral perspectives
into their own and the wrong they don't
hold up when you when you scrutinize
them and the cure for that is more
reading looking at other perspectives in
ethics and moral theory and then you
start seeing some of the gaps some of
the flaws in utilitarianism even in its
best proponents utilitarianism can go
along with them and actually in practice
does go along with some pretty horrific
things as well as so many good things
oftentimes utilitarian thinking is just
what the doctor ordered but when you're
trying to think of moral theory you want
to have a toolbox that's got more than
one tool in it so day ontological or
duty base topics very important virtue
ethics very important natural law theory
has some things going for it I think
that it's important to study these sort
of things before trying to hammer
everything with with a hammer even if it
requires a reg saw a screwdriver
well there you go i mean the word that
you choose tells you what's going on
indoctrination whether it's by peter
singer or john rawls or an R and or
anybody you know who's sort of a big
name famous philosopher whose also kind
of superficial as all three of those are
it's not going to be any good actually
even indoctrination by Plato or Hagel or
you know some some real first-rate
philosophers if it's just indoctrination
it's not real philosophy at that sort of
antithetical to them the very spirit
that animates philosophy down through
the ages so I would encourage you to
take a look at that if you admit to
yourself that you've been indoctrinated
you know what you need to do which is
read a lot more and have an open mind as
you're reading Peter Singer just as a
footnote yeah I'm radam not very
impressed in part because I think he
doesn't get other people right and that
is a a sign to me of a lower grade
thinker they they fit everything into
the schema that they've got and within
that schema they're very coherent that's
why it's attractive to people reading
philosophy early on it provides a
coherent worldview but hey you know part
of the test of whether something passes
muster is whether you can get other
people who don't already by the program
to see some something to the program so
that's what I'd encourage you to think
about and hopefully this isn't too harsh
so this is a great question great in
part because I've got a great answer for
it that you wouldn't even suspect by the
way that the question is framed with
nature versus nurture how does
philosophy and lighten that perspective
with society well here's the thing is it
just nature versus nurture is at the
whole picture that's what they tell you
in class and some of your classes right
but that's not the case and here's
something that philosophers or at least
some philosophers know about and
theologians know about and some some
literary people know about but
psychologists sociologists
anthropologists they've totally lost
sight of we have will's we have a
faculty of the will we don't just have
intellects we don't just have appetites
this is something that was discovered
along the way and philosophers have
given a lot of thoughts of this and
there are different theories out there
some of them may be more right than
others but you'll never know about it
unless you actually read some philosophy
or read some theology read some
literature and if you do can be quite
illuminating why don't the scientists or
the social scientists want to treat it
well because it's not easily treated it
doesn't fit into the sort of matrices
that their disciplines require and which
doesn't mean it's not real it means that
there's a huge huge aspect of reality
the metaphysics of ordinary life and
moral life and a few many actions that
they can't take account of no matter how
many ways they quantify it statistically
or study it then missing out on
something fundamental we do have a
faculty of the will and if you want to
study it that's place to do it
philosophy
do I think people were more moral in
Plato's time than ours I'm whole no I
think that they had somewhat different
issues that they were struggling with
and they had a culture that in some ways
made it easier for them to choose paths
that were moral or you know at least to
some degree morally justified but i
think that they faced a lot of the same
basic perennial problems that people did
a hundred years later a thousand years
later and you know in our time and we'll
a thousand years from now as well
there's certain constants of human
nature that aren't going to go away and
each generation has to do it over and
over and over again because you know you
come you come into this world without
having some sort of automatic moral
sense or compass that's going to tell
you what to do and you learn about
what's right and wrong through cultures
that are by themselves you know sites
where people are trying to get over and
where things don't always work the way
they're supposed to and people provide
bad examples as well as good examples
and where there's a lot of arguments a
lot of you know discord about what's
right and wrong I mean that's the way
right and wrong is by the way it's
always going to be that way some people
are always going to be saying that the
wrong thing is the right thing and vice
versa so I don't think that we should
say that that people were in fact more
moral and Plato's time as a matter of
fact I think one of the reasons why
Plato is writing what he is and actually
suggesting it's kind of utopian in his
own time is because most people were you
know either just soso with their moral
life or we're actually kind of badly off
same thing in Aristotle's time same
thing in Thomas Aquinas same thing for
can't so you know same
well unfortunately i don't have any good
answers for you this one good
introductions to natural law theory
because when I actually teach a natural
law in the classes where I get to do it
and you know quite frankly I haven't
gotten to teach anything like a
graduate-level ethics course or you know
some some study just of natural law by
itself so i'm teaching things in survey
classes i actually just start with
Thomas Aquinas and I talk about the
general notion of natural law and you
know we work through a bit of that and
that's usually enough for them to wrap
their heads around after we go through
the most general precept and
three more specific precepts and then
start applying them to cases and all
that there is a whole literature out
there there are people who specialize in
that sort of thing and I have to admit
that I found many of them really
scholastic and almost Delta fying Lee
boring and there you know some of them
are people who are associated with the
you know quote unquote revival of
natural law like you know finis and r is
a but again not my cup of tea Jack Moore
attend I was a pretty nice little book
on a natural law that you could check
out Alistair McIntyre has has talked
quite a bit about it as he moved from
you know Aristotelian virtue ethics
conception to it's a mystic natural law
conceptional so I would look around and
some of his works but for contemporary
stuff I think you need to find somebody
who really likes that kind of literature
and specializes it i said it's best just
to go back to Thomas you know